[Musique]
les recommandations qu'on a fait vise à
redonner du sens à redonner du souffle à
l'hôpital public c'est pour ça qu'on a
intitulé ce rapport sortir des urgences
il faut arrêter de courir après le temps
pour les personnels de courir après les
moyens sans cesse il faut des réformes
structurelles qui redonne sa place à
l'hôpital public dans notre système de
santé et qui redonne du sens à ses
personnels pour cela il faut jouer en
effet à la fois sur les rémunérations
certes mais notamment des rémunérations
d'heures supplémentaires qui ne sont pas
prises en compte il faut aussi jouer sur
la qualité du travail le cadre de
travail mais aussi les conditions de
travail il faut aussi renforcer bien
évidemment les effectifs dans les
services nous souhaitons aussi
travailler sur le financement de
l'hôpital et puis nous avons fait tout
un volet sur comment l'hôpital se situe
dans le système de soins pourquoi il est
tellement congestionné donc il faut
travailler en effet sur avec la médecine
de ville avec
les autres professionnels de santé puis
bien sûr c'est de proposer des mesures
concrètes pour restaurer l'attractivité
de l'hôpital et faire que les soignants
reviennent à l'hôpital parce qu'on a
constaté aussi que le ségur la santé
s'il a amené des revalorisations
importante et bien malgré tout n'a pas
fait revenir les soignant à l'hôpital ce
qui est clair c'est que ça a été à une
mission intéressante où je pense que
nous avons entendu beaucoup de monde
nous les avons écoutés et j'espère que
que et se retrouveront dans les
propositions nous sommes dans ce rapport